[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the local police department using
podcasts to try to solve murders from a
2015
unsolved fatal shooting to the 1996 cold
case of a teen's murder
she did not deserve that
she had a little girl heartbreaking
testimony as an eleven-year-old takes
the stand
against his stepfather describing the
alleged murder of his five-year-old
brother
he went in there and beat him the tiger
king star is facing more legal trouble
why the big cat zookeeper says he needed
to blow off steam
after his exotic animals were seized
plus the prosecutor's theory for where
the missing wife of a millionaire real
estate heir
might be buried and how he's tying it
back to the murder of susan berman in
the trial of robert durst
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a police department in florida is hoping
a new podcast
could help crack murder cases that have
gone cold lawn crimes angela levy is
here with two stories of two different
killings
brian podcast as you know are incredibly
popular especially among true crime
fans so the boynton beach police
department in florida hopes that the
podcast could be the key to finding
victoria miller's killer
she had a sweet soul alexis miller was
only eight years old when her older
sister victoria was murdered in may of
1996.
she was a good person deep down she was
she was a mom a sister and a daughter
sarah miller was only 10 when victoria
died i just
saw it the way it broke my mom's heart
it's really
that's i think what sticks out the most
what it did to her
victoria's body was found in a field in
boynton beach
after she went missing her throat had
been slashed
she went to a party and nobody saw her
again after that
um a few days later she was found in a
field she was naked and wearing only
shoes
boynton beach police detectives want to
close victoria's case
once and for all we had an intern come
in and
generate this podcast idea and we
thought it was a great idea
um and she did an excellent job at it
the rosebud podcast tells the story of
victoria's murder
anything no matter how small it may be
could help us out tremendously boynton
beach detectives also want to solve the
murder of edward morton who was shot at
the door of his mother's home in 2015
she has begged for clues in the past
this is my second son
that got killed i don't know why
i was killed but i would love to know
why
police say the shooter came to the door
of the home and asked for edward
his brother christian can't identify him
this sketch
came from his description that's what we
think will
will lead to this case being solved this
is somebody knowing
what happened and just telling us and
then hopefully
we can show a picture to christian and
he can identify them
now boynton beach police would also like
to use a podcast to help generate some
clues
in edward morton's case as well brian
thanks angela joining us today is the
editor of crimestory.com
carrie antholous and terry austin carrie
what about this podcast makes it so
intriguing and possible for true crime
experts such as yourself
to help i think this phenomenon of
citizen sleuths whether they're
reporters podcasters documentarians or
authors
is is part of our the explosion of media
around the world if you think about
michelle mcnamara and her efforts to
solve the golden state killer case
that culminated in the arrest of the
golden state killer
or if you think about the work that
andrew jarrecki and mark smirling did
with robert durst
and a lot of the evidence that they
accumulated in
doing their film actually resulted in
durst getting arrested for
the murder of susan berman um this is a
you know this is
ever growing and as the cost of the
technology becomes
less and less it's much easier for
people to
get on the uh get on the uh on the trail
of these
crimes and help solve them absolutely i
mean terry this
is an intern from the police department
who's hosted the podcast and puts it all
together
she believes that miller being found
with a tennis shoe was odd what about
this case stuck out to you as odd
well i thought that was odd brian but i
was struck by the fact that the system
really
failed victoria she was in different
foster homes
she was you know subject to domestic
violence
she didn't receive adequate treatment
for her drug and alcohol abuse
and a loophole in florida law enabled
her to work in the topless bar
at the age of 16. so i just think
overall that's what strikes me about
this case the system really failed her
that seems like it and jeanette what
evidence do you please have in
victoria miller's case you know they
have had some suspects in the past brian
and they also have
some dna evidence they wouldn't
elaborate on what kind of evidence it is
but they do
have the dna they just need a profile to
match it to
and then obviously they would need
something some other type of evidence to
corroborate that dna evidence so they're
really hopeful
that giving this case a fresh look after
25 years
could finally lead to her killer
hopefully i was talking about it here
and people going to the podcast will
help generate some buzz generate some
information
to help crack those cold cases thank you
everyone now to ohio where a former tv
star is charged
with an alleged inappropriate contact
with a teenage girl
jared drake bell has pled not guilty to
misdemeanor charges of child
endangerment and disseminating matter
harmful to juveniles
police say the 34 year old's arrest is
related to a 2017
incident with a then 15 year old at one
of his concerts
prosecutors say the teen had established
a relationship with bell
several years prior bell who now goes by
drake campana was on the nickelodeon
sitcom
drake and josh he's currently a spanish
language singer
based out of mexico bella is out on 2
500
bail and is due back in court on june
23rd
a suspect in a high speed chase in
florida is accused of throwing a baby at
law enforcement
as he tried to escape the indian river
sheriff's office says john henry james
iii
tossed the two month child in an
apartment complex dashcam in aerial
helicopter footage shows part of the
chase
as deputies attempted a traffic stop the
sheriff says james ran over stop sticks
and hit a detective's vehicle law
enforcement then appear to stand down
when they follow james to a parking lot
according to the sheriff
james grabbed the baby from his back
seat throwing the child
the deputy caught the baby who's
reportedly safe and sound
still ahead on law and crime daily a
tiger king star is in some legal trouble
and this time we're not talking about
joe exotic but first
an 11 year old takes the stand against
his stepfather in the murder trial of a
five-year-old autistic boy
the gut-wrenching testimony next
welcome back turning now to tennessee
where an 11 year old boy is testifying
about the night his little brother went
missing
and what led up to the arrest of his
stepfather for murder
he went there and beat him like i said
alex was just
eight years old when his brother baby
joe went missing his stepdad
joseph ray daniels on trial for the
murder of five-year-old joseph clyde
daniels
alex says the defendant beat the boy
with a whip then
they all went back to sleep later that
night alex says he woke up
to a loud bang i saw him laying on the
ground
who was laying on the ground joe clyde
yes
and what was the defendant doing he
he was about to pick him up and carry
him out the door
he said that he'll tell me if i didn't
help him i saw him walking down the road
with him
carrying joe claude yes according to
alex
it all happened because of an accident
when you say that he peed in the floor
was that in the bedroom in the bedroom
okay
and after joe claude peed in the floor
what did you do
i went and told told who
and when you're pointing at him you're
pointing at the defendant yeah
in court the now 11 year old referred to
his stepdad only as him
and to his mother by her first name
crystal on cross-examination the defense
asked alex
if he initially told a different story
do you recall
telling a different story no i actually
do
but it was faith it was a false story
the defense then played videos of alex's
interviews with child services
shortly after baby joe went missing
trying to show inconsistencies with his
testimony
does anyone get involved with him
did daddy ever butt with anyone yeah
in another interview alex said no one
told him what to say
or not what to say prosecutors point to
one striking comment which they say
could explain alex's inconsistencies
[Music]
the fact that joe was missing made you
feel scared but you feel safe that dad's
in jail
yes how do you feel now
what makes you feel confused
back with us to the editor of
crimestory.com carrie antholon terry
austin terry you heard alex's testimony
he was eight at the time of the incident
do you think his testimony was credible
i do brian but it was very difficult to
listen it was very moving testimony we
know that alex was
very close to baby joe clyde and they
went on the bus together and we remember
the testimony
from the speech therapist who said that
they were close
but as far as his credibility is
concerned the inconsistencies are
a problem but what i'm hoping is that
the prosecution will bring a
psychologist to the stand
and talk about how these inconsistencies
might have occurred the eight-year-old
might have been
afraid to speak out against his father
whereas now three years later he's 11.
he has more clarity and he has more
courage so if i were the prosecution
that is the way i would explain those
inconsistencies
now carrie on the other side the defense
seems geared to point the finger at the
mother do you think they'll argue alex
is just trying to protect his mom
um perhaps although a lot of it
i think a lot of it depends on what the
emotional tenor
is of the witness if if that witness
in the videotape seems scared and
in articulating why his story changed
expresses that he was in fear then
i think that will be compelling for a
jury i think the
it feels like the defense has a very uh
steep hill to climb on this one brian
yeah now terry what did you make of the
cross examination and the types of
questions that the defense made
against such a young witness i think he
actually came a little bit too hard at
this witness he's very young i think
he's sympathetic
and the jury is listening to this and
when you come
too forcefully against a very young
witness
i think it is going to be used against
the defense and
uh you know here i would not have done
that i might have even passed on that
absolutely definitely a technique we
talk a lot about here and then watching
the testimony because of course law and
crime covers
uh all of these cases gavin or gavin
we've got our commentators saying
exactly what you're saying terry so it's
interesting that you picked that up
because i think a lot of people are as
well
and an update to a case we've been
following closely at law and crime
a judge in iowa denied a mistrial
request from the man convicted
of killing college student molly
tibbetts
christian boneja rivera was found guilty
of stabbing molly tibbis to death
and hiding her body in a cornfield his
defense said one of the state's
witnesses watched the live streaming
coverage of the trial
but the judge found the defense did not
provide any example
to prejudice from the viewing the
defendant is scheduled to be sentenced
on july 15th
coming up on law and crime daily how the
prosecution is alleging robert durst got
rid of his wife's body
in the 1980s plus tiger king's stars
jeff lowe's legal troubles are growing
his latest arrest for dui and claims he
was blowing off steam
after authorities seized his big cats
next
[Music]
we're back two of the stars of the
netflix series tiger king
are speaking out after their arrest for
allegedly driving under the influence
jeff lona's wife lauren were arrested
saturday around 1 50 a.m
in oklahoma city police say they saw a
white range rover with the license plate
tiger king
jump a curb and leave a parking lot at a
high rate of speed
lauren reportedly was driving and pulled
over at the cops request
then spoke in a slurred speech jeff is
accused of getting out of the front
passenger seat
walking around and then driving the car
into a parking lot
according to the report he had a strong
odor of alcohol and blew a .18 at the
police station
the couple is known for their appearance
in tiger king murder mayhem in madness
jeff lona's wife took over the animal
park once owned by joe exotic
last month federal authorities seized 68
lions tigers and lion tiger hybrids from
the park
a judge found probable cause the couple
violated the endangered species act
as well as the animal welfare act now lo
was taking to instagram saying quote
we want to apologize for the poor
judgment we displayed it's been a long
painful couple weeks losing our children
the way we did while burning off steam
friday night
we lost track of just how many people
were handing us drinks
back with us at the editor of
crimestory.com carrie antholous and
co-host terry austin
terry seems like an open and shut dui
case to me and what did you make of that
uh
apology case closed brian i mean look he
had a strong odor of alcohol he didn't
pass the gaze
test he didn't pass the breathalyzer
test
and you know the fact that he admitted
to blowing off steam and he apologized
for
his poor judgment i think really is
going to be used against him
and drinking while intoxicated is no
joke i mean he could actually go to jail
he could you know have a suspension of
his license
certainly could be on probation so this
is a serious charge
yeah and again he blew a .18 just a
reminder the legal limit is point
zero eight so just a little a little
over the top
uh carrie tiger's taking dui could this
be the continued fall
of the tiger king's kingdom um
yeah when when you get involved with a
documentary
you're rolling the dice and when you get
that kind of notoriety
that a netflix series will give you then
you're you're standing on a pedestal and
every
misstep will lead to you know could lead
to some misery
in this case it led to people giving
them drinks and it led them getting
arrested it seems
yeah that's a high fall from a netflix
series uh podium i guess is the way to
put it
uh thank you both for that input and
yeah we'll see how this story of the
tiger king's kingdom continues
as we will probably hear more uh for her
legal troubles from both sides but still
nothing from kerry
carol baskin when we come back was a
popular spot
used by tony soprano's crew to bury
bodies also used by real estate heir
robert durst
why the prosecution believes a
millionaire's wife's body is buried
there
ahead
welcome back prosecutors of the
millionaire real estate air are
revealing their
theory for where robert durst's missing
wife might be buried
robert durst is on trial in california
for allegedly shooting and killing his
lifelong friend
susan berman in december 2000. durha's
first wife kathy vanished from her new
york home in january 1982.
investigators say berman helped durst
cover up kathy's death
and was killed because she threatened to
go to the police prosecutor john lewin
told jurors in opening statements
that durst buried kathy in the new
jersey pine barrens
made famous by the tv show the sopranos
for the soil
not freezing in the winter a phone
records analyst testified about four
collect phone calls placed
at or near the pine barrens to the durst
real estate organization
two days after kathy's disappearance
it's on february 2nd at 12 23 pm
again the person is standing in beach
haven new jersey
calling vandoorne realty asking
vandoorne to pay for the call yes
call is at february 2nd at 4 55
p.m over four hours later and now
they're in barnegat new jersey
and they're calling vandoorne realty
asking vandoorne to pay for the call yes
are you familiar with where beach haven
and barnegat new jersey are yes
they're on a uh on long beach island the
pine barrens of
new jersey the coast very sure pine
barrens is a very large
rural area that very sandy soil it's
a lot of state parks it's just a big uh
you know
not not a lot of people live or there's
not a lot of businesses there
is this a vast remote area yes
prosecutors also alleged susan berman
called kathy durst medical school
pretending to be kathy to help cover for
durst but on cross
the defense asked if kathy made a quick
phone call would it even show up on the
phone records
hi dr cooperman this is kathy durst i'm
not feeling well
i'm vomiting i have diarrhea i have a
headache
i can't make my rotation would you
please help me
dr cooperman yes i will i hope you feel
better
oh and by the way uh dr cooperman i
understand from dean cook
that you might call me is that less than
three minutes
special agent the way you said it was
yes okay
and the way dean cooperman said it was
also but
let me ask you this i'll with i'll
withdraw i'll withdraw that well that's
to complete your hypothetical
so so that wouldn't that wouldn't
register here
being a local call less than three
minutes all i could say is if
whatever was said was under three
minutes it would not register
carrie what do you make of the
prosecutor's overall theory now that
he's added durst got rid of kathy's body
soprano style well
the it's a compelling argument to me
um the pine barrens uh
were have been a notorious burial ground
for the
mafia since the height of the gambino
crime family when the mafia that we'd
know from the godfather was
was at its height um
susan berman had very deep ties to the
mafia her father
was a uh was the mob liaison in las
vegas
after bugsy siegel was assassinated she
might have known she'd just written a
book about her father
and so she might have known and advised
bob about
where to bury the body um it's uh
it's very compelling information that
combined with the fact
that the new york city detective
struck's
investigation of it was very compromised
and his testimony
that was played last week his
pre-recorded testimony
was very damaging to the defense and
my guess is that the defense was reeling
all weekend from the
impact of strzok's testimony on top of
all of that
there's this thing called the dig note
or that's become known as the dig note
which
robert durst has now acknowledged having
written which is a
list of implements that could be used to
bury a body
um including um the word
dig um the the word boat
um the the the word shovel
and um durst um has now acknowledged
writing that
that combined with being down in the
pine barrens
and the disappearance of kathy's body
never to be seen
or the disappearance of kathy durst
never to be seen
is i think very incriminating and and uh
makes the prosecution's case very
compelling now
terry the four collect calls still
circumstantial evidence but a lot more
direct than some of the evidence been
seen
otherwise does this give a clearer
picture of the opportunity that durst
had to hide durst
to hide kathy's body well first let me
just say i agree wholeheartedly with
carrie here
and listen circumstantial evidence can
be just as strong as direct evidence
fingerprints
are circumstantial evidence but that
might be stronger in some cases than
witness testimony
so i think the fact that he was out at
pine binds
making those calls strong evidence thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you